the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC ladies and gentlemen welcome inside
the new studio I know it looks very much
the same but it is very much different
and I know it will probably sound a
little different for a couple of days
dealing with an echo you don't need to
email me about the echo we're dealing
with it's still treating the room uh
please bear with me as we work through
some technical elements here and I know
it looks like I have a wire coming out
of my right arm and I do it's been
implanted to connect directly to the
studio no I'm kidding let's get right
into it because there is so much to talk
about it is not yet over in Arizona in a
number of different ways and of course
it is completely over in Arizona in
terms of Kerry lake is not going to be
the next Governor from Arizona so let's
take it step by step in Maricopa County
they they held and by they I mean the
county authorities and people who
believe Carey Lake actually won they
held a hearing and the hearing was so
insane and so depraved and so outrageous
that within just moments it went bad I
want to look at a couple of these
moments with you again as a reminder
that these people will go for years you
know how sometimes you look at a little
puppy dog or a toddler and they seem to
have endless energy and you say well
I've already thrown the ball a hundred
times I've already picked up the spoon
500 times and it's still interesting and
you still want to do it again and the
answer is they will go for years they
are still not over the results of the
2020 election and now they are getting
going with 2022 here is a woman who says
she is there air somehow related to
wanting a new election and also her
children were once taken away from her
which is certainly odd take a listen to
this
why is nobody talking about us over the
media
I am nobody like I'm just like mother
trying to save my family because my kids
were taken from me when they were little
because I fought for them medical
freedom because so it sounds like the
children were taken away for for reasons
of neglect and this is the person who
knows we should have a new election I I
don't go there okay but I want to tell
you this guys
um
I feel this like a joke but please
Arizona I love Arizona I love all of you
I love you Stephen I voted for you okay
this is not about hate uh Love and Hate
You Know What Love Is to say no to wrong
doing you know and and please try to
understand those people how upset they
are yeah everybody's very upset because
they're candidate lost and yet they want
a new election because of that if we won
it was fair if we lost it was rigged
here is another woman who believes there
were hundreds of thousands of people in
Arizona who could not vote there's a
statistician online that's already done
statistics on these guys it's a
statistician who's done statistics what
else do you need disenfranchisement
based on Richard's numbers and how he
calculated people waiting in line it's
up for hundreds of thousands of people
that we're not able to vote right that
they disenfranchised the second thing is
everybody that's been paying attention
for way years before 2020 and then when
2020 came along and they've been paying
attention since then do not trust these
machines there have been investigations
going Mike pillow is one of those guys
going on for two years the evidence is
in they've got it all they're gonna it's
gonna bubble up to the Top If We Had
journalists that were doing their job
and asking questions people would know
this by now but they don't so here's my
next point it's going to Bubble Up This
is a fork in the road right now today
now by Bubble Up it sort of sounds like
she's increasingly saying that this
might lead to violence and again think
of it 2.4 million people voted in
Arizona a few weeks ago she says
hundreds of thousands were
disenfranchised that sort of means like
a third of the electorate or at least 10
15 20 it's Bonkers now then came another
woman who was even more dire and
apocalyptic in her concerns she says if
this election gets certified it's going
to get very bad very quickly Justice you
high and mighty politicians don't even
know the meaning of the word fairness
which of you has any left not one all
your dealings are crooked you give
Justice in exchange for bribes these men
are born Sinners lying from their
earliest Words Their poisonous deadly
snakes cobras that close their ears to
the most expert of Charmers so this is
this is like biblical stuff right oh God
break off their fangs tear out the teeth
of these young Lions Lord let them
disappear like water into thirsty ground
make their weapons useless in their
hands let them be as snails that
dissolve into slime okay I think you
basically get it just crazy apocalyptic
stuff here is an another woman who came
forward and said that the board of
electors in Maricopa County are Traders
Tony
false and personal look at the seven
traitors to the United States
Constitution okay again please
to receive a subpoena this morning at 9
30.
what did you do you called your meeting
for 8 am
what are you hiding right we all know
nothing good happens at eight in the
morning if you hold an 8 A.M meeting it
must be for some kind of subterfusion
then lastly here's a guy again with just
more like apocalyptic Bible type stuff
and then he throws in some Klaus shop
World economic Forum conspiracy theories
imagine getting out of bed for this some
people traveled from other states which
by the way what stake do they have in
Arizona that's a whole other question
the wicked flee when no one is chasing
them but The Godly are bold and lion
you see any bold people who are lions
here I see bald people
they're committed to this thing so am I
when there is moral rot within a nation
it's government topples easily but with
honest and sensible leaders there is
stability I want you to feel [ __ ] so
there is this guy and they are going to
achieve nothing they continue to be
convinced that they are right that they
actually won despite there being no
evidence whatsoever
Kerry lake is playing along with these
people Carrie Lake continues to say oh
it's not over it's this that the other
thing it is over and there is one
Arizona county who refuses to accept it
let's talk about that next there is a
republican-controlled county in Arizona
that is Cochise County or it may be
pronounced goat cheese it's not
completely clear to me and they're
refusing to certify the election as the
Associated Press is reporting Republican
officials in a rural Arizona county
refused yesterday to certify the 2022
election here we go again it's the same
stuff one this is the sequel my friends
a decision that was quickly challenged
in court by the state's top election
official now I want to make an important
distinction here
Steve Bannon and some others when it
comes to 2020
continue to talk about decertification
we have to decertify the election there
is no such process there's just it
doesn't exist
this here is a different situation where
they are saying let's not certify
certification is indeed a process and
the Secretary of State Katie Hobbs is
the Democratic candidate who won and
will be the governor
she has asked the judge to order County
officials to Canvas the election which
she said is an obligation under the law
so there's a couple different things
going on here and of course no matter
what is going on these right Wingers
will come up with some reason why they
are actually correct and everything is
absolutely right that they want to do
when they want to do it but anytime
there's a different perspective then it
must be somebody who's doing something
wrong it's fraud it's whatever the case
is going to be
the practice that they are getting here
is to refuse to certify a federal
election it's important to understand
that these are always trial balloons for
the next thing and refusing to certify a
state election at the county level is a
trial for a state refusing to certify a
federal election at the state level if
this were to happen or in any way even a
fraction of it were to happen
they would use it as precedent for the
future that's number one secondly this
isn't legal okay it is absolutely
correct to go to court to try to force
certification and these are folks who
have been given a duty a task an
election has taken place the ballots
have been counted now you have to
certify there is no analogy to Bannon
saying well there's a duty to decertify
decertification isn't a thing these
elected officials have no duty to
decertify elections you're you're put in
a certain position County Board of
Elections you have to certify they're
not doing it it's a legal issue that's
why they're going to court now I know
where they are going to ultimately find
the certificate and it's going to be of
course in Hunter Biden's laptop or on
Hillary hard drives emails right no uh I
believe that the grounds here that they
are claiming are of course completely
imaginary this is going to be certified
and then they are going to say this is
proof
that they stole it because they came in
and forced us to certify something that
shouldn't have been certified of course
it's simply their job to certify this is
still potentially very dangerous because
almost no matter what ultimately happens
with this attempt not to certify they
are going to say well here's the next
thing that now we have to do at the next
election which happens to be 2024
presidential where Arizona along with a
handful of other states could determine
who's the next president of the United
States very scary stuff I don't think
this will come as a surprise to many of
you but under Elon musk's stewardship
for lack of a better term Twitter is no
longer enforcing its coveted
misinformation policy CNN has an article
about this where they write Twitter said
it will no longer enforce its
long-standing covet misinformation
policy yet another sign of how Elon Musk
plans to transform the company he bought
a month ago CNN writes that in 2020
Twitter developed this set of rules that
prohibits or seeks to prohibit quote
harmful misinformation about covet and
the vaccines and we all know as CNN
summarizes that between January of 2020
and September of 2022 Twitter suspended
more than 11 000 accounts for breaking
covet misinformation policy Twitter is
no longer going to do that they did not
appear to formally announce the change
but some Twitter users last night
spotted a note added to the page on
Twitter's website which says effective
November 23 2022 that's about a week ago
Twitter is no longer enforcing the
covid-19 misleading information policy
they don't explain why but they simply
say it is no longer being enforced what
is important to understand here is that
this is all part of a package of changes
being brought to Twitter under the false
pretense the false pretense that Twitter
became over the last couple of years
some kind of woke left-wing
disinformation or forced information or
speech policing platform we know that's
not the case from independent studies
done about messaging on Twitter but also
there were so many people overtly
spreading coveted disinformation that 11
000 accounts were suspended part of what
Elon Musk has been doing is restoring
many of those suspended accounts to
their former
Glory I guess they would say and this is
just part of it what do I think is
ultimately going to happen with Twitter
I really don't know
there are some who are sure that Twitter
will evaporate and go away I just don't
think so I think there's too many people
on the platform will Twitter be weakened
by fleeing advertisers and user
abandonment it's completely plausible
but there is no question that Twitter is
changing and people have written to me
and they said David I've noticed with
tears they said David I see you're not
tweeting as much uh there is something
that just makes me not that interested
in participating on the platform hey
nobody I'm not under the pretense or
delusion that everybody's out there
waiting for my tweets
I'm not making I'm not making a
statement of any kind I just see that
the engagement quality has declined
I see that the Twitter blue thing has
also not been particularly exciting and
I'm just less interested in posting to
Twitter that's all that's going on where
we will be three four months from now we
will see but officially now coveted
disinformation maybe not welcomed but
certainly allowed on Twitter
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at a fair price
guys know how tough it can be to find
good boxers and t-shirts the Search is
Over All boxer briefs by Leisure of NYC
are made with amazingly soft moisture
wicking viscose from bamboo it feels
super lightweight like air it doesn't
Bunch up it's also great for the planet
Leisure of NYC also makes these
incredible supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts for men less than one percent
of men's Basics today are made with
supima cotton it's the best out there it
feels like Silk quite frankly you can
walk around in a scratchy t-shirt all
day or you can enjoy the cloud soft feel
of supima cotton and actually love the
shirt you're in these are my go-to
shirts and boxers nobody else even comes
close to the Comfort they provide all
products are fair trade with
sustainability in mind pick some up for
yourself or someone on your holiday
shopping list go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below
the David Pacman show continues to be a
community and audience supported program
we really do depend on your support we
have something called the membership
program you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you get The Daily Show no
commercials in audio or video formats
you get the daily bonus show remember
that thing which Alex Jones really hates
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves as bad yeah very very bad and
also invitations to the members only
Town Hall sign up at joinpakman.com
coupon code always available 24 starts
now or please no more Trump that's
another coupon code please no more Trump
speaking of which Donald Trump throwing
democracy in the toilet and flushing it
10 to 15 times at 2 30 in the morning we
knew he was up to something weird in the
middle of the night didn't we Donald
Trump saying that Kerry Lake
should be installed as the governor of
Arizona you know if you go back and look
at the history of generally speaking
overwhelmingly the 20th century but also
to some degree the 21st and you look at
leaders who were quote installed
it's not a particularly good history and
that is exactly what Donald Trump is now
demanding happen in the middle of the
night Donald Trump posting to his
platform truth social
well call it what you want quote massive
numbers of quote and fully capitalized
broken
voting machines in Republican districts
on Election Day capital letters
everywhere none of them make sense
mechanics sent in to quote fix them made
them worse Carrie had to be taken to a
Democrat area which was working
perfectly to vote now understand that
none of that is true
her opponent ran the election this is
yet another criminal voting operation so
obvious Kerry Lake should be installed
governor of Arizona this is almost as
bad as the 2020 presidential election
remember it's almost as bad because
nobody's the bigger victim than Trump
which the unselect committee refuses to
touch because they know it was capital F
fraudulent
look at what is happening here this went
from Summer 2020. well you know
there might be problems that Democrats
take advantage of because of mail-in
voting and early voting no evidence of
it but it was a much smaller claim to I
won I won and they stole it from me in
November of 2020. now to install the
loser
install the loser make her the governor
even though she actually lost if we win
it's a fair election if we don't bring
out the pitchforks demand a new
elections say it's fraud and blah blah
blah blah blah now one of the craziest
things about this
is that Kerry lake is still insisting
that they're going to get this one back
now much like with all of these people
we don't know to what degree are they
grifters to what degree are they Liars
to what degree are they victims
I am struggling to believe that Kerry
lake has even a one percent belief that
they are going to somehow get her to be
the governor of Arizona and yet she just
posted as a reply to Donald Trump's
truth quote arizonans have no faith and
trust in our elections and what's
notable is she capitalizes Faith trust
and elections just like Trump does very
weird she goes on to say our election
officials are incompetent or worse they
have failed us the fake news ignores our
fake elections and expect us to just
quote move on
we won't America will not survive if we
don't demand election reform now do we
think for a second that Kerry Lake
really believes she is going to be
appointed the governor of Arizona
installed as the governor of Arizona
declared the winner of the governor of
Arizona race
I am really struggling to believe that
and what I think is actually going on
here is that this is Carrie Lake's
continued addition to be Donald Trump's
vice presidential running mate in 2024.
Marjorie Taylor green has made it clear
she wants to be Trump's running mate in
2024 and Kerry lake is making it clear
as well and as I've said before not all
of the people claiming that 2020 was
stolen really believe it some of them
say it because they realize that it is
the thing you're supposed to say if you
are showing your allegiance to Donald
Trump's team
and I believe that that is part of what
is going on here as well if you believe
that Kerry Lake believes she is going to
be the governor of Arizona let me know
in the comments and make sure you're of
course subscribed on YouTube in order to
be able to comment at youtube.com the
davidpackman show we're continuing to
very closely look at the December 6
Georgia runoff between incumbent
Democratic senator Raphael Warnock and
challenging Republican uh candidate
Herschel Walker now we've already talked
about how Herschel Walker has no
business being senator from Georgia I'm
going to give you yet another example of
that a little bit later on in the show
but one of the interesting questions has
been is Donald Trump going to show up to
try to help Herschel Walker Barack Obama
is showing up to try to help Raphael
Warnock that we know and he will be
campaigning with him but Donald Trump
has is apparently so toxic at this point
in time that Republicans are trying to
keep him as far away from Georgia and as
far away from Herschel Walker as
possible New York Times reports Trump
plans limited role in Georgia Senate
runoff the former president who held two
big rallies before the state's two
runoff elections two years ago both of
which Democrats won will steer clear of
Georgia
before next week's senate election and
when you look at why
you very quickly understand it a Michael
Bender writes for the New York Times
Donald Trump will not cross the Florida
state line to campaign with Herschel
Walker during the final week of the
Georgia Senate runoff election after
both camps decided the former
president's appearance carried more
political risks than rewards campaign
officials for the two Republicans said
Monday do we believe that Trump was
sitting there going you know what it's
true I've become such a ticking time
bomb and a hot head and liability that
it's probably best that I not go
probably not it's probably the people
around Trump
who got together with those running
Walkers campaign and said we're going to
try to keep them away Trump is planning
a call with supporters and will continue
sending online fundraising please for
Walker now those online fundraising
please default to 90 of the money
actually going to Trump and here is sort
of the key line of the article the
decision to keep Trump out of the
spotlight was a response largely to the
former president's political style and
image which can energize his core
supporters but also motivate Democratic
voters and turn off significant segments
of moderate Republicans one other really
interesting element of this in Georgia
that political math has become a net
deficit for Trump
that's a critical line
who opened his 2024 presidential
campaign two weeks ago in 2020 he was
the first Republican presidential
candidate to lose the state in 28 years
earlier this year his hand-picked
primary Challengers Governor Brian Kemp
and Secretary of State Brad
raffensberger were both trounced this is
more interesting
in terms of 2024. now I don't want to
diminish the importance of getting that
51st senate seat in Georgia
the data is looking pretty good for
Raphael Warnock we never count our
chickens before they CA hatch we never
um you know you use whatever metaphor
you want
that is an election we have to fight for
we're going to be covering it including
up to uh the live results on December
6th
but there's another component to this
which is
what is Trump's path to victory in 2024
and what I mean by that is if you start
with the 2020 map and you say what was
marginal here you certainly look at
Georgia now the problem with that math
is flipping Georgia alone from 2020
won't give Trump the presidency so you
need Georgia and something else or you
got to flip Pennsylvania
George is increasingly looking bad for
Trump and part of that signal
is exactly what's happening in Georgia
right now so when we think about can
Trump win and listen I was one of the
guys that a week before the 2016
election said I think Hillary's got it
in the bag and I was wrong so I am not
going to fall for this again
particularly two years early and say oh
Trump has no path to victory in 2024.
the difference is we've seen what a
trump map looks like
and Georgia is an important part of that
map Georgia is an important signal when
we think about 2024 and George is
looking so bad for Trump that he's being
kept away when it comes to Herschel
Walker that's why it's so critically
important right now let me know what you
see as Trump's map and path to Victory
there
um and maybe we'll even do we're not
going to do maps between now and
November of 2024 but maybe we'll do one
sample map to sort of look at what it
could be send me your thoughts make sure
that you are subscribed on YouTube make
sure that you are following us on
Facebook at facebook.com davidpackman
show much new content coming the white
paper on how to talk politics without
ruining relationships is now available
at davidpackman.com guide a thousand
people have already downloaded this I am
stunned we were thinking well if 250
people download this thing it's probably
a good start a thousand people have
already downloaded this guide it is free
at davidpackman.com guide
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with Dr
John Crystal who's a psychiatrist and
Yale University Professor may be best
known for the discovery of the rapid
antidepressant effect of ketamine in
depressed patients uh Dr Crystal really
great having you on I appreciate it
really uh pleasure to be here today so
maybe to start with before we talk about
ketamine specifically it'd be great to
hear from you a little bit about
depression more generally you know you
talk to five different psychiatrists
you'll often get five at least slightly
different answers about to what degree
is depression situational or caused by a
chemical or hormonal imbalance or some
combination or it depends on the
particular case what's your sense of our
best understanding about depression at
this point
sure so I I think there are some things
that we can all agree on one that it's
far more common than we ever thought
two that it has far more detrimental
effects on people's lives than we
probably had previously appreciated
and and three that a lot of people who
try to get treatment for depression find
that the treatment that they start out
with isn't giving them the kind of full
response that that they're looking for
and and as a result even for many people
who are in treatment depression
continues to take a toll on them and I
think another thing that we would agree
about depression is that um it's really
fundamentally different than having a
bad day now we've all had a bad day
we've all probably had moments of of
Despair even but to sit in that state
all day every day or most of every day
um is a totally different experience
that is hard to appreciate if you
haven't been through it yourself
and so
um when we get to questions of causes we
have to appreciate that there are an
enormous depression is a very broad term
and there are probably many different
kinds of depressions and unfortunately
this is one area where Psychiatry has
not really
um
led us to a satisfactory place in other
words we appreciate that there are
different types of depression that
people might have some that are purely a
reaction to
um bereavement or getting fired or
having your marriage break up and where
where you have an issue or a problem
that you just can't kind of work through
in it and it and it takes you down into
this really negative place
but there clearly are other people who
have depression that comes on as you
point out because of a hormonal
imbalance because of a medical problem
uh because of other other kinds of
things going on in the body and and
we're we know a lot more about the
interplay between the body and the Brain
in relation to depression that we than
we ever did before and one of the things
that we've learned is that medical
problems in the in the body heart
disease asthma
arthritis all of these things even
obesity
um can contribute to a process in the
body called inflammation which when we
think of inflammation in our joint we
think of a sore joint when we think of
inflammation in the brain it affects the
way that the circuits are regulated and
can contribute we think to depression
but but there is also probably a genetic
contribution about 30 or so of the risk
for depression is is genetic and one of
the things that you can see in some
people who don't have a major life
stress and don't have a medical problem
contributing is that some people out of
the blue just part of their own makeup
will will experience into depression and
that's that's really important in all of
these cases
uh you know whether it's a primarily
stress primarily hormonal primarily
um uh genetic vulnerability they're
still we're talking about this very kind
of complex interplay of a person in
their surroundings and and so it's not
surprising that we treat depression
sometimes with Psychotherapy sometimes
with medications sometimes with both and
and other things like getting a lot of
social support getting good exercise
having a healthy diet can all help
people uh be uh make get their best
chance of of recovering from their
depression so before we talk about
ketamine just briefly
um treating depression with ssris from
the research I did before our interview
it seems like it's pretty clear that the
ssris work better than Placebo they
don't necessarily work
at numbers that are incredibly
overwhelming it's not 90 but it does
seem better than Placebo is that still
your understanding and what exactly are
ssris doing in the brain yeah so
um so first absolutely ssris are
extremely helpful for many people and
and so I'd say if if people were just
starting their
um of having their first experience of
depression and they get treated with
with an SSRI that they could expect
about a 50 50 chance of of getting
better from that that SSRI but the
reality is that that
um that one of the things that we've
learned about depression for many people
perhaps because of the complex interplay
that we were talking about is that it
can be a chronic or recurring disorder
and so what sometimes happens uh is that
people who maybe in their first episode
responded to the SSRI find that late
later on the medication isn't working so
well
so how ssris work is to raise the level
of Serotonin bathing the brain by
preventing its reuptake after release so
it does increase the brain's exposure to
to
um to uh depression and then it's the
brain's reaction to having so much
serotonin around that evokes adaptive
changes in the brain that that help the
regulation of mood in other aspects to
function better and
um and this process is dependent on the
ongoing availability of serotonin in the
brain so if you stop the SSRI abruptly
many people will find that their
depression symptoms will come back or if
you just deplete the body of Serotonin
to deplete the brain of Serotonin even
though people are staying on the on the
SSRI medications who may have a
transient relapse and that was done for
research purposes to help to understand
how these medications work so that's a
general introduction to the ssris so
let's now talk a little bit about
ketamine
um maybe what what is ketamine what were
some of the early medical uses that at
least it was tested for and then how did
this start to become something that was
thought of as maybe effective for
depression
yeah well to me it's a remarkable story
so ketamine
is a drug that was identified as an
anesthetic medication in the in the
1960s
and a a a a good friend and and
colleague
Dr Ed Domino
first gave this drug to people and
helped to describe its peculiar effects
which he and others called dissociative
anesthesia which is its capacity to
produce a kind of Twilight state that
those people sometimes called
dissociation
and
um the uh they didn't know how it worked
when they discovered it in fact uh the
field of Neuroscience really didn't
figure out how uh ketamine worked until
the 1980s
and then what we've what was found out
then was that ketamine works by blocking
the action of glutamate at one of its
receptors called the nmda subtype of
glutamate receptor now you might say
wait I've heard of Serotonin before I
haven't heard of glutamate and and how
is that why would you think of glutamate
for depression so this gets back to in a
way the logic that carried us to test
ketamine first into press patients which
is that for a long time from from the
first identification of these
transmitters to I'd say certainly the
the the mid to late 1990s maybe even
later most people thought of depression
as a disorder of the norepinephrine like
noradrenaline or serotonin systems of
the brain these are chemical systems in
very primitive parts of the brain that
project to the higher centers of the
brain and tune the activity of these
higher brain Setters so they reasoned if
serotonin was a ride not functioning
right maybe if we give we give
um a serotonin reuptake inhibiting drug
will treat the symptoms of the
depression by normalizing serotonin
well
um researched by several groups
including the work done here at Yale by
my colleague Dennis Charney and Pedro
Delgado George henniger and others they
showed that if you deplete the body of
Serotonin you don't produce depression
if you deplete the body of
norepinephrine you don't produce
depression and that the biology of
depression is is is more complicated in
some ways this was a kind of
intellectual crisis moment for the
thinking about the biology of depression
and and the way that uh Dr Charney and I
reasoned our way around this problem was
to say well maybe if depression doesn't
predominantly live in the serotonin or
norepinephrine nerve cells themselves
maybe depression lives in the targets of
of norepinephrine and serotonin the
higher brain centers and the two main
brain centers we thought of were the
cerebral cortex the highest executive
control of our thought and behavior and
emotion and the limbic system the
generators are drivers of emotional
experience in the brain
and and with that came a kind of an aha
moment which is if
if
um depression is a cortical disorder
not not a brain stem disorder then the
intrinsic signaling mechanisms of these
higher saying brain centers the main
information highways of the higher brain
centers
should be involved in depression in its
treatment
and those information higher uh
information highways involve the
neurotransmitter glutamate as the main
excitatory neurotransmitter of the
cortex like 90 of the synapses so we
thought Let's test a drug that blocks
one of these glutamate receptors the
drug we chose to do that was ketamine
and what we found was this rapid
Improvement in mood Within
24 hours say of of a single dose Academy
in a large number of the people we
tested what is the dosage idea when it
comes to ketamine is it the type of
thing that is a is taken daily like an
SSRI do the effects fall off similarly
or differently like is it how how would
it be administered right so so
um Time magazine called ketamine the
anti-antidepressant and and that is
because it doesn't work like anything
else we know first unlike a medication
that you give a little bit of the drug
you don't have much effect of the drug
and you take it every day as part of
your daily life that's not at all what
ketamine is like what ketamine is is you
give a dose that that is high enough to
be to trigger the antidepressant
response
and
um and those antidepressant effects last
a week or two uh for in people and so
people generally start getting two doses
a week then after a month or so one dose
a week then every other week and so when
people are maintained on it if they need
to be maintained on it they they may
only get a dose once every three weeks
or once a month and by spreading it out
people don't become tolerant to it they
tend to if anything to become uh more
sensitive to the antidepressant effects
and it turns out in the long-term data
with s ketamine the S the the version of
ketamine developed by Jansen
that it's very helpful in preventing
relapse of depression and so that it's a
good long-term treatment as well as a
strategy for producing a rapid
antidepressant response and to help
people who haven't previously responded
to antidepressant medications are the
doses large enough when they are given
that they have a sort of psychoactive or
maybe dissociative type effect
when given in the way that we end both
we and our laboratory with ketamine and
later Jansen with s ketamine
give ketamine yes they tend to produce
psychoactive effects they can make
people feel Spacey they can have altered
sensory perception they might experience
for example that their arm or their
fingers feel longer or they may have a
feeling that the room is breathing in or
out and what we find is that if we
prepare people for those kinds of
effects if we're with them when they are
having those experiences and then if we
can have the chance to talk about them
afterwards that that people can both
understand what's going on not find it
very frightening and and have overall a
good experience last thing I wanted to
ask about what's the the sort of
regulatory and legal status right now of
using ketamine in this way per the FDA
yes so s ketamine the S isomer of the
ketamine molecule ketamine comes in two
mirror images and so one of the mirror
images uh the S isomer of ketamine is
developed in a by Jansen and approved by
the FDA for the uh treatment of
treatment resistant depression and
depression in the context of suicide
risk
the standard ketamine that's used in
anesthesia is approved by the FDA for
anesthesia right and what that means is
that doctors can prescribe the racing at
ketamine for the whatever they want but
it is not approved by the FDA for the
treatment of depression and that means
that doctors who are prescribing this
form of ketamine have some additional
liability because it's not endorsed by
the FDA also the consequence of it not
being approved by the FDA is that some
insurance companies only cover the S
ketamine version that the s-ketamine
version is given as a nasal spray
um and people take a certain number of
puffs of the nasal spray that's
appropriate for them and worked out with
their doctor
and uh and uh that version of of as
Academy that that version of ketamine
the S Academy is FDA improved and and
increasingly covered by insurance and
Medicare and Medicaid we have been
speaking with Dr John Crystal who is a
psychiatrist and Yale University
Professor really interesting and we look
forward to reading more about the these
uses I really appreciate your time today
it's wonderful wonderful to be here and
to talk about this area so thanks for
having me on
you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's take a look at a couple of other
things you know one of the things I
really hate is hypocritical people and
people who project who say you're this
you're this you're this when really I'm
the one who is this and there is no
greater example of this than the rights
view on speech and free speech and we
are all about being the party of speech
we saw during covid that what they
claimed to be be wanting to be the party
of free speech became something very
different it became we get to tell
everyone what content they have to allow
on their platform wait a second doesn't
Twitter then before it was owned by Elon
Musk doesn't Twitter have these uh
almost
um god-like free speech rights as a
company which we shouldn't regulate to
decide what sort of content do they want
on them on their platform that's their
speech no they should be forced to allow
people to spread drinking urine cures
covet or whatever it is that they want
to spread we know that they are complete
and total Hypocrites and I have
unfortunately a downright dangerous
example of this for you today
Georgia Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker
says that he wants protesters arrested
if they're protesting after 5 PM
it's not a free speech Zone
it's a free speech time you can have the
free speech during business hours on
weekdays and if you've got to work a job
then screw you sorry you can't protest
listen to this and one thing people got
upset about me because of course
everybody's right to a piece of protest
and I know during these times we have
that we can put something in in place
and I said peaceful protest let's say a
piece of protests from eight in the
morning to five in the afternoon yeah we
all have the night that means the host
loves it big problem so you need to go
home and you all get arrested that's
from then zenzel movie you either want
to go home or go to jail because it's
not peaceful anymore right by definition
it's not peaceful after 5 PM I guess if
you have a day job sorry you can't
protest this is not free speech my
friends the government shall not and not
infringe on anyone's speech
before 5 PM and then after 5 PM
everybody's got to go home now there's
two different layers to this okay
I unders to pretend that Herschel Walker
has any idea what he's talking about for
a second
I am open to the idea
that a 3 A.M protest is far more likely
to degenerate into trouble and violence
and whatever then a 6 PM protest I'm
with you on that most municipalities
already have noise ordinances
and all sorts of other infrastructure
which apply uh rules about blocking
streets and sidewalks and all sorts of
different things okay but the idea that
eight to five is when any kind of
protest is allowed isn't supportive of
free speech isn't supportive of exactly
the values that these Republicans claim
to be supportive of now I don't really
expect Herschel Walker to know or
understand any of this as he you know
quite literally as he runs for Georgia
Senate from his house in Texas that's
his Texas house that's basically where
he lives the idea of well he Georgia
okay let's not even get into that but
the imagery is particularly stunning
here he doesn't understand anything
that's going on but it is yet another
example of how these Republicans claim
to be all about a
and sometimes they are quite literally
against a
and as is again the case
we have to take a step back and say is
this the intent of those who were the
creators of the Constitution and the
framework that we have in the United
States when it comes to not just issues
of speech but issues of freedom of and
from religion where now they say well
freedom from religion not really and by
freedom of religion really they're
talking about Christianity and oh okay
so freedom of and firm religion actually
really just means establishing
Christianity okay
you go through these one by one by one
and you start to see they don't actually
practice what they preach when the
rubber hits the road or when it comes
time to put your money out whatever
phrase you want to use
it's just stuff that they say until it
becomes inconvenient that's the bottom
line my pillow uh CEO and founder Mike
Lindell known colloquially as pillow
almost like Cher or Madonna or Kanye
maybe for a better example
he is now running for chairman of the
Republican National Committee
this is absolutely the best this guy is
increasingly cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs and
I can think of no more logical choice to
run such a Nutty party than Mike pillow
here he is on real America's voice we're
still trying to figure out what that is
explaining he's running this here is to
is a hundred percent all in I've seen a
big the RNC is one of the most important
organizations in our country and is
sinking the ship is going down and it's
you know it needs a leader and it needs
a business leader it needs someone that
knows how to fix things by the way
can we be done with we need a business
person to lead the country here there or
the other place prior to Trump we really
didn't have any examples of business
people making good presidents we now
have had a business person president one
of the worst disasters that I can
remember
and now they want to do it again in
another position I mean listen if you
want to ruin your party would that go
for it it's not making too much sense to
me how to be proactive in moving forward
with a change in Footprints I've put the
footprint of our country has drastically
changed it it's went all over the board
things that things that you thought that
you could always count on you can't
count on anymore you can't you know and
uh so no this is a hundred percent
um a need and believe me people came to
me that sort of perspark this these were
big donors and when the big donors are
going to leave and when they are in C
when you have all its own members going
hey we want to
um their donors aren't given and uh and
your and your party is going to crumble
and it would it's already you can't if
they don't have a plan of something
different coming in a different input
you're going to get the same output
Steve so I say to that you want you want
to make this you you want to succeed uh
you get you get me elected uh today all
these states where you know one of those
168 people that I'm going to call each
and every one of them yeah okay so
listen pillow's running is this just
what Republicans need is he in a sense
the most logical choice I hope that this
happens I think it would be an absolute
disaster for the Republican Party one of
the I am not a fan in any way of of Ron
Rona Rona McDaniel Ronald McDaniel uh
but at least she was from the wing that
sometimes would realize hey you know
it's probably not great for us for Trump
to come to Georgia to help Herschel
Walker he's probably doing more damage
than than helping at this point in time
she had some connection to reality in
terms of Maga even if I find her
politics completely deplorable pillow is
a guy who will go what we need is Trump
we need Trump everywhere we need
lawsuits everywhere we need to talk
about how we won every election that we
actually lost and we know how that
turned out for them in 2022 so I welcome
Mike pillow running here we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P
I got a voicemail from a guy who he
calls pretty frequently
he seems to think I'm still talking
about Bernie Sanders
now I supported Bernie twice
I believe that Bernie's time has come
and gone
I don't think Bernie's even thinking
about running in 2024 I haven't talked
about Bernie in months but here's a
caller who seems to be under the
impression
that I'm still talking about Bernie
gotten into the White House except for
the fact that he's an actual economic
and social populist okay so couple
different things here first of all I've
already gone through the math
it's very popular to say Bernie
definitely would have beaten Trump had
he been the nominee in 2016.
um I have not actually seen the evidence
of that I voted for the guy in the
primary in 2016. I have not actually
seen a compelling mathematical case made
for why Bernie would definitely have
defeated Trump in 2016 where Hillary did
not Bernie couldn't even win the primary
well it's because the DNC okay yes to
some degree that's true
but I have just simply not seen the math
of that
Donald Trump
Bernie's
Donald Trump received an inordinate
amount of artificial help otherwise the
American people would have never voted
for a lifelong con man and career
criminal and fast talker end up fully
like Donald Trump part of me it sounds
like this guy is stuck six years ago I
think he's talking more about 2016 than
2020. uh guys I gotta we're going to
listen to a little more of this I have
to tell you I don't know why I'm getting
a phone call about this I I haven't
mentioned Bernie even in passing in
months and it seems like this caller is
talking about a six-year-old election
we know that and that's not unique to
Trump you and I both know that
has there anything given a a an honest
Level Playing Field to compete with he
would have easily won the White House we
both know that I I just don't know that
be honest with yourself
receiving in or amount of help he
received help from the corporate media
from the leadership of the democratic
party that's right and of course the
Republican Party listen there's another
minute and a half to this voicemail I'm
not going to play it
I don't fully understand whether the
issue is this guy thinks I've been
talking about Bernie
or that this guy is still rehashing a
six-year-old election yes we look at
history to understand what what is going
on and to understand the future of
course I understand that
but I just don't really know what's
going on and it's worrying me a little
bit let me know what you think always
always welcome all calls but sometimes
speech has consequences and it might be
me wondering what the hell is going on
we have a great bonus show for you today
um we have been following the World Cup
in Qatar Qatar Qatar everybody has a
different pronunciation okay that's not
what the issue is
uh someone ran onto the field with a
rainbow flag during the match between
Portugal and Uruguay
Uruguay please folks one of my favorite
teams by the way and this of course
relates to a lot of the extreme
right-wing Insanity of Qatar we're going
to talk about it on the bonus show
number two San Francisco is considering
a law that would allow law enforcement
robots to use lethal Force
is that a good idea it's sounding like a
very bad idea we're going to talk about
it and thirdly a Florida woman has sued
Velveeta claiming that its macaroni
takes longer than three and a half
minutes
what does that make any sense what are
the damages well we're going to talk
about all of it and more on today's
bonus Show Ladies and Gentlemen please
get the bonus show oh the bonus show are
you and make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
well it makes money to fund the show and
pay salaries and pay health insurance
and do the things that good employers
try to do Alex thank your lucky stars
every day you're not Dave Pacman well
that's fine uh I fortunately I don't
have a billion dollar settlement against
me
bonus show joinpakman.com
you sign up you get instant access and
again I want to remind you we have a new
free offering it's all funded by the
same membership program we have a I
believe it's an eight or nine page white
paper
building arguments without Burning
Bridges people call in I can hear them
crying they have tears they say David
I need to talk to my crazy uncle about
his right-wing politics but I don't want
to ruin the relationship
we have a guide for how to talk about
politics with people and how to at least
get them to reconsider their views it is
free it is completely free at
davidpackman.com guy we will see you on
the bonus show and back here tomorrow
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
they're Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpackman.com NYC